Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 269, das kurz und prägnant Geld, Kunst und die Lösung all unserer Probleme heißt. Und ihr werdet vielleicht schon mitbekommen haben, wenn es um die Lösung all unser Probleme geht, dann kann es sich bei dieser Sendung nur um die Blockchain handeln. Oder fünf, mal sehen, das werdet ihr im Laufe der Sendung noch herausstellen. Wir reden also heute über diese Technologie, die immer wieder mal durch die Nachrichtenwellen schwappt. Meistens, wenn Bitcoin ein neues Hoch hat. Und dann habt ihr vielleicht ab und zu, also in meiner Teilen ist das so, NFTs ist so ein Begriff, der rumschwimmt, irgendwas mit Kunst und Blockchains. Und dann ist ein weiteres Thema, was man ab und zu mal hört, so, Länder große Mengen von Energie werden für das Erstellen von seltsamen Digitalwährungen erstellt. Diesen ganzen Themenkomplex wollen wir uns heute mal angucken. Und wir machen das sehr selten bei Chaosradio. Aber heute ist vielleicht eine Sendung, wo ein bisschen Vorwissen gefragt wird. Also wir versuchen, das alles noch wirklich auch mitzuliefern, aber wahrscheinlich nicht sehr ausführlich. Das ist aber nicht so schlimm, weil es gibt ein Chaosradio, wo wir das schon mal in den Grundzügen geschaffen haben. Das ist das Chaosradio 169, glaube ich. Es ist genau 169, das ist also 100 Sendungen her. Damals haben wir als Bitcoin noch relativ neu war, genau darüber gesprochen, und sozusagen ein bisschen von den Grundlagen, sowohl technisch als auch dieses, was ist eigentlich ein Krypto-Geld oder eine Kryptowährung, das ist da schon so ein bisschen erläutert. Wenn ihr also ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz neu in dem Thema seid, könnte es sinnvoll sein, das zuerst zu hören. Jetzt begrüße ich aber die Gäste der heutigen Sendung, das sind Peter Leppelt, hallo.
NFT steht ja für Non-Fungible Token. Das heißt nicht Tokens, auf denen keine Pilze wachsen. Schade. Ja, da wäre sie ja für was gut. Das Non-Fungible bezieht sich, also Fungible heißt austauschbar, ersetzbar. Und was das ist, ich kann dir einen Euro geben, damit kannst du was anfangen. Ich kann dir ein anderes Euro Stück geben, damit kannst du ganz genau dasselbe anfangen. Also ein Euro Stück ist gegen ein anderes Euro Stück austauschbar. Ein Geldschein hat eine Seriennummer. Das hilft dir jetzt bei einem Geldschein nicht sehr so viel weiter, aber tatsächlich, also der Geldschein ist im Prinzip auch austauschbar, aber es ist nicht derselbe Geldschein, weil er hat eine Seriennummer. Und jetzt sind fiffige Leute auf die Idee gekommen, was ist denn, wenn wir in die Seriennummer Informationen reintun? Du hast einen Geldschein, der ist aber eigentlich nicht sozusagen einen festen Geldbetrag wert, sondern der ist das wert, dass eine bestimmte Seriennummer draufsteht. Und das ist dieser Non-Fungible Token. Und jetzt gab es also diese Idee, man könne ja zum Beispiel den Besitz an einem Kunstwerk mit Hilfe eines solchen NFTs entkoden. Ist natürlich, wenn man näher hinguckt, so ein bisschen schwierig, weil, naja, da steht halt drin, keine Ahnung, ich besitze die Spinde mit den sieben Beinen, aber natürlich hindert das niemanden da dran, sich eine Kopie von der Spinde mit den sieben Beinen zu machen. Das ist halt nicht die Mona Lisa, die einmal im Museum hängt, sondern das ist ein String, wo drin steht, mir gehört die Mona Lisa. Und wenn überhaupt, dann gibt es möglicherweise ringsrum ein Vertragswerk, wo drin steht, dass mir die Mona Lisa gehört, aber das Vertragswerk geht ja nicht weg, nur weil der digitale Token weg ist. Also, ich finde es, du hörst vielleicht schon raus, ein relativ unüberzeugendes Konzept. Und es geht sogar so weit, dass also in der Praxis, steht dann also in so einem NFT, ist da nicht etwa die Mona Lisa encoded. Es ist auch nicht ein Link auf die Mona Lisa encoded, es ist ein Link auf eine Webseite encoded. Und auf dieser Webseite steht, hallo, das ist übrigens ein Anteil an der Mona Lisa. Also in dem Moment, wo die Webseite weg ist, ist auch der Besitz an der Mona Lisa weg, bei so einem NFT. Hat natürlich aber dazu geführt, dass Leute 6-stallige Millionen, 7-stallige, 8-stallige Beträge bis hin zu 100 Millionen, weil die größte NFT-Transaktion durch die Gegend geschoben haben.
Also nur noch mal, damit ich es richtig verstehe. Es gibt also eine Blockchain. Und in dieser Blockchain sozusagen sind die einzelnen Coins, oder wie auch immer man das nennen will, die da sozusagen generiert werden, enthalten auch wieder ein Häufchen Daten. Dieses Häufchen Daten ist ein Link, und zwar ein Link auf einer Website. Auf der Website steht dann, dir gehört digitales oder analoges Kunstwerk so und so.
Also wie ich mir das immer erkläre, ich sage immer, ein NFT ist wie eine Garderoben-Marke, das auf ein bestimmtes Fach verweist. Also es geht darum, das ist die Fähigkeit von einem NFT. Es kann auf etwas verweisen, und zwar auf Beliebiges. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mir vorstelle, ich habe an der Garderobe einen Mantel abgegeben, der ist 1500 Euro wert, dann bekomme ich den theoretisch sicher zugestellt, den kann ich dann auslösen über diese Marke. Wenn jemand an meinem Mantel interessiert ist, brauche ich eigentlich auch gar nicht den Mantel aus der Garderobe holen, sondern theoretisch könnte ich dem einfach mal eine Garderobe Marke für denselben Preis geben. Sagen hier 1500 Euro, kriegst du meine Marke und damit gehört dir der Mantel. Diese Person müsste mir natürlich vertrauen, dass dieser Mantel da wirklich in der Garderobe hängt, dass er das wert ist und dass man den da irgendwie rausbekommt oder auch nicht. Der Joke bei der Kunst ist, dass niemand die Kunst aus der Garderobe rausholt, sondern es im Moment nur darum geht, sagen zu können, ja, ja, das gehört mir und meistens kriegt man das tatsächliche Kunstwerk dann noch irgendwie gratis hinterhergeschmissen als Datei-Download oder Unlockable-Content.
Also das ist wieder mal nur ein Spekulationsobjekt, weil da geht es nicht ums Übertragen der Besitzrechte an etwas, sondern nur um einen Besitznachweis sozusagen. Und das ist beim Digitalen dann nochmal absurder, weil du den Mantel ja beliebig oft vervielfältigen kannst. Oder Max, kannst du mir das vielleicht erklären? Ich habe das manchmal gelesen als der Versuch, den Besitz von Kunst, der ja im Analogen ganz physikalisch stattfindet, da gibt es halt nur eins oder nur eine Serie von, das zu übertragen aufs Digitale. Ist das eine Idee dahinter gewesen?
Unter anderem definitiv. Soweit ich weiß, ist das allererste NFT, das jemals gemintet wurde. Das war so ein kleines Kunstwerk. Das wird auch gerade bei so einem großen Auktionshaus versteigert. Das ist 2017 bei einer Konferenz gemintet worden. Durchgesetzt hat sich die Technologie vor allem, um zum Beispiel Items in Computerspielen zu übertragen. Ich habe mir bei irgendeinem Computerspiel eine besonders tolle Rüstung erkämpft oder Schwerter oder sonst was und die kann ich jetzt jemandem verkaufen und übertragen. Da dieses NFT die Fähigkeit hat, auf alles zu verweisen, kann ich eben auch plötzlich Sachen übertragen, die ich vorher so niemandem übertragen kann. Niemand hätte ein Schwert, das er sich im Computerspiel erkämpft hat, irgendwie auf eine CD gebrannt, um es irgendwem zu schicken. Inwieweit das jetzt absurd ist, was da läuft, ich versuche das immer so zu vergleichen, wenn ich ein Haus kaufen würde, dann läuft ja auch erst mal nur ein Grundbucheintrag. Es kommt ja niemand, der mir ein Haus gibt, dass ich mir dann in die Hosentasche stecke. Und wenn ich mir Aktien von der Lufthansa kaufe, dann kriege ich ja auch nicht ein Stück von einem Flugzeug zugeschickt, sondern ich muss auch darauf vertrauen, dass mir dieser Teil gehört. Da gibt es natürlich die ganzen Institutionen dahinter, die das sichern, dass das alles so abläuft, als hätte ich wirklich ein Teil von der Lufthansa dann am Start. Aber im Prinzip ist das nicht viel anderes.
Und das wirft dann auch schon wieder die Frage auf, warum dann Blockchain? Also wir kommen eigentlich immer wieder bei der gleichen Frage auf. Man nimmt Blockchain, dann ist es Spekuliererei oder man macht es halt anstrengend.
Ich habe eine kurze Detailfrage zur NFT. Ist NFT eine ganz spezifische Blockchain oder ist das eine Technologie, für die es dann schon auch wieder verschiedene Blockchains gibt?
Also es gibt ganz verschiedene. Vor allem wird NFT gerade auf der Ethereum Blockchain gemintet, weil die besonders dafür geeignet war. Da beschweren sich natürlich gerade alle, dass die Transaktionskosten viel zu hoch sind. Also das kann teilweise mehrere 100 Dollar kosten. Eine Transaktion und das wäre zum Beispiel einfach nur das einmalige Einstellen eines Kunstwerks, das Minden eines Kunstwerks. Da gibt es Blockchains, wenn man das über Algorand oder über Tesos macht, da ist das dann direkt um ein tausendfaches effizienter, günstiger, auch energieeffizienter. Soweit ich weiß, soll das über Polygon sogar komplett umsonst möglich sein. Aber grundsätzlich eine Technologie, die über verschiedene Blockchains möglich ist. Angeblich auch über Bitcoin, wobei das nicht so gut geeignet sein soll und deswegen da noch nicht so viel drauf läuft.
Ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen sozusagen, ich laufe gerade so ein bisschen ins Leere, weil ich dachte, dieses NFT, das wird ein riesiger großer Themenblock, aber letztlich ist es halt genau derselbe Quatsch in grün. Aber Max, trotzdem mal gefragt, das ist ja, wenn wir versuchen, drüber nachzudenken, was könnte das Positives bringen? Da hätte ich jetzt den Verdacht, na ja, also im Prinzip ist ja, der Künstler, der arme Künstler, der kräftige arme Künstler, der hätte hier vielleicht die Idee, Digitalkunst zu erstellen und die auch irgendwie zu verkaufen.
Ja, also es sind gerade die Digitalkünstler, die das Geld nutzen. Also völlig abgesehen davon, dass das auch jetzt am Anfang vor allem auch wirklich als Propaganda von irgendwelchen Kryptobillionären angesehen wird, die einfach nur die ganze Menschheit in die Kryptomärkte reinziehen will. Witzigerweise ist das auch tatsächlich das, was sich beobachten lässt. Also ganz, ganz viele Leute sind gerade Anfangs des Jahres jetzt ins NFT-Business eingestiegen, haben versucht, eigene NFTs zu minden, zu verkaufen. Und wenn das nicht erfolgreich lief, haben sie dann versucht, stattdessen mit Kryptowährung Kohle zu machen. Also falls das der Plan dahinter war, hat das sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Das Versprechen, was dahinter war, ist, genau wie du es am Anfang gesagt hast, das Durchsetzen von Urheberrecht im digitalen Raum. Zum Beispiel bietet NFT die Möglichkeit, über Smart Contracting an seinen digitalen Werken zu verdienen, auch bei Weiterverkäufen, was bisher so nicht möglich war. Das heißt, wenn Picasso sein erstes Bild damals, als er unbekannt war, für 50 Fr. verkauft hat, und das ging irgendwann für 50 Mio. weg, hat er persönlich daran nichts verdient. Jetzt kann man bei einem NFT, wenn man das mintet, direkt von Anfang an einstellen, wie viel man verdient, sobald es weiterverkauft wird. Das wird dann über Smart Contracting automatisiert erledigt. Dann werden Beträge dem Konto gut geschrieben, so dass je nachdem, wenn man eine große Sammlung hat, die eifrig gehandelt wird, durchaus ein ganz gutes passives Einkommen zustande kommen kann. NFT bietet vor allem auch am Anfang die Möglichkeit, sich selbst direkt zu vermarkten, ohne dass man als Künstlerin angewiesen ist auf große Galerien, die bisher meistens als Gatekeeper funktionieren, weil man mit seiner Ware sofort an den Markt gehen kann und sofort in der entsprechenden Community auch an erster Stelle der Aufmerksamkeit ist. Und vor allem bietet es überhaupt für Digitalkünstlerinnen zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit, ihre rein digitale Kunst sofort zu vermarkten. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch einfach ein perfektes Timing. Man muss sich vorstellen, die Corona-Pandemie hat natürlich besonders die Künstlerinnen hart getroffen. Da sitzen ganz, ganz viele Leute zu Hause, die überhaupt keine Möglichkeit haben, auszustellen und ihre Kunst an den Mann oder die Frau zu bringen. Die haben die Festplatte voll mit Digitalkunst, die aber eben noch nicht gedruckt wird, um sie irgendwem zu übergeben. Und auf einmal bietet sich die Möglichkeit, einfach die vom Heim-PC sofort ins Internet zu stellen und über Nacht damit reich zu werden. Und das ist natürlich ein Versprechen, was sich in vielen Fällen bewahrheitet hat. In noch viel, viel mehr Fällen leider nicht. Aber natürlich sehr, sehr, sehr lukrativ ist. Und deswegen war da gerade Anfang des Jahres, als auf einmal die Preise so explodiert sind, das wurde schon angesprochen, da wurde auf einmal ein rein digitales Bild für 69 Millionen US-Dollar verkauft. Also da war natürlich der Run groß und der ist immer noch da. Also bei Facebook in den entsprechenden Gruppen sind jeden Tag Leute, die sich noch erklären lassen wollen, wie kann man NFTs machen, um damit Geld zu verdienen.
Aber ich bin gespannt, wie Sprache funktioniert. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Bild zu verkaufen. Aber es ist ja eben nicht so, dass das Bild verkauft wird, sondern es wird einen Link auf der Webseite verkauft, wo drauf steht, dem und dem gehört das Bild, oder?
Das ist jetzt eine philosophische Frage. Das ist wie mit dem Haus. Wird sein Haus verkauft oder wird da der Eintrag im Grundbuch verkauft, der verspricht, dass man dieses Haus benutzen darf? Das ist, also im Endeffekt wird nichts klassisch übergeben, so wie man im Supermarkt halt einkauft. Aber das ist man eigentlich in vielen anderen Bereichen des Lebens schon gewohnt. Aber definitiv, es wird nichts direkt übergeben.
Nee, aber beim Grundbucheintrag ist ja Folgendes. Das ist natürlich sozusagen eine Repräsentation, die da verkauft wird, aber es gibt halt eben nur ein Haus. Bei dem Kunstwerk, bei dem digitalen Kunstwerk, das kannst du ja kopieren, unendlich oft. Und dann wird sozusagen die Repräsentation wertvoller als das eigentliche Ding. Dann geht es also nicht darum, das Kunstwerk zu besitzen, also die Datei in den Händen zu halten, sondern es geht nur darum, dass irgendwo steht, dass du der rechtmäßige Besitzer bist, oder?
Ja, zum einen ist das so. Zum einen ist das natürlich sehr wertvoll, behaupten zu können, ich bin der Besitzer von dem und dem Werk oder von der Mona Lisa oder...
Aber auch nur, weil es ein Spekulationsmarkt ist.
Ja, also ich sage mal so, ich vergleiche das immer so, wenn Picasso einen Druck von einem Bild angefertigt hat, und dann hat er, was weiß ich, 50 Drucke angefertigt. Die sind dann viel wert, weil die von ihm sind. Wenn, sobald Picasso dann die Druckerei verlässt, der Drucker dahin geht und dann einfach nochmal 100 Stück davon macht, dann wären das keine Original-Picasso's mehr. Also, und das ist eben was, was durch NFT sozusagen sichergestellt werden soll. Das ist jeweils von diesem einzelnen Künstler oder der Künstlerin gemacht worden. Und es ist eben nicht nur eine direkte Kopie, die mehr oder weniger komplett identisch ist, bis auf vielleicht den Zeitstempel. Ich meine, da gab es natürlich jetzt auch so Vorfälle, Stichwort Sleepminting, wo Leute einfach sich in die Wallets von KünstlerInnen reingeschlichen haben und quasi ohne deren Wissen in deren Namen Kunstwerke herausgegeben haben und sich selber verkauft haben. Solche Fälschungen, die sind auch schon passiert.
Die Niedertracht des Menschen kennt keine Grenzen.
Es ist für mich völlig faszinierend, was für eine wie abstrakt Besitz in dem Fall geworden ist. Also es kann jeder kopieren, es sind dieselben Bits, aber ich kann sagen, es ist meins. Und dafür gebe ich irgendwie zweistellige Millionenbeträge aus.
Aber wie stehst du denn selber dazu, Max? Weil die, was ich am Anfang vorgelesen habe, hast du ja wirklich gesagt, du hast dich gegen potenzielle Auktionsgewinne abgesichert. Das ist ja das Antithema. Findest du das eigentlich eine coole Idee? Oder eigentlich denkst du, das muss angezündet werden und gehört weg?
Also das Letzte finde ich natürlich einfach direkt schon mal sehr sympathisch. Ich bin da sehr, sehr, sehr gespalten, was das angeht. Also zum einen glaube ich, pardon jetzt, irgendwas wollte ich gerade vorsagen, das ist mir jetzt ein Fall, ich muss mir mal überlegen. Also zum einen fand ich es natürlich total absurd, auch die erste Reaktion, die jeder hatte, wieder bezahlt jemand für ein rein digitales Bild so viel Geld. Das kann doch gar nicht wahr sein, das ist da absolut der Bullshit, was da für Millionen weggeht, das kann ich mir mit einem Rechtsklick runterladen, hab dasselbe und kann dann sagen, guck, ich hab sie auch auf meinem PC drauf. Also das wirkt erstmal total absurd. Und andererseits, das ist jetzt nur mal am Rande, könnte das sogar so eine kleine Rettung sein für dieses kapitalistische Versprechen des endlosen Wirtschaftswachstums trotz begrenzter Ressourcen. Also das ist ja, sind ja in den allermeisten Fällen sind das ja auch Leute, die mit Krypto viel Geld gemacht haben, die gerade dort die Preise extrem hoch treiben. Also in dem konkreten Fall von dem Beeple-Werk, das dort für 69 Millionen weggegangen ist, wird mindestens unterstellt, dass der Käufer, der dieses Werk so teuer gekauft hat, dass der gleichzeitig schon eine Kollektion von Beeple besaß und aus dieser Kollektion selber wieder eine Mehrwährung gemacht hat, an der man Anteile kaufen konnte, an der wiederum Beeple selber mit Anteilen beteiligt war. Das bedeutet, der Käufer, der dort 69 Millionen bezahlt hat, der war eigentlich traurig, dass er nicht noch mehr bezahlen durfte, weil es ihm darum ging, den Preis unterstellterweise so hoch wie möglich zu treiben, weil dadurch natürlich auch die anderen Kunstwerke, die er in seiner Sammlung besaß, noch mehr Geld wert gewesen wären. Man muss auch irgendwo vielleicht auch ein bisschen dankbar sein, dass die Leute, die da ihre Krypto-Milliarden verdient haben, die eben dann in digitale Kunst irgendwo, wo es keinen anderen stört, reinschieben, als sich zum Beispiel auf einmal Schrippen zu kaufen, weil ansonsten plötzlich die Schrippen zwei Euro kosten würden oder noch mehr, wenn die diese Kohle, die die da machen, auf einmal in den normalen Geldmarkt reinschieben würden. Irgendwie ist es gut, dass diese absurden Krypto-Gewinne auch im Kryptomarkt bleiben. Für mich persönlich, also ich hatte wie gesagt diese allererste Reaktion, das ist doch total absurd, was da läuft, und wollte dann auch entsprechende Kunstwerke machen oder da entsprechendes Statement zugeben. Das allererste, was ich gemacht hatte, war, was sich da für mich abzeichnet, ist zum einen dieses Auseinanderklatschen, von was ist etwas wert und was ist der Preis. Also eine digitale Datei, die man beliebig kopieren kann, die ist für mich nichts wert. Die Arbeit dahinter, die zu erstellen, die ist auf jeden Fall was wert, aber die Datei da selber, wüsste ich nicht, warum man für eine gratis erstellte Kopie was bezahlen müsste eigentlich. Und gleichzeitig sind da so krasse Preise für bezahlt. Deswegen war mein allererstes Kunstwerk, was ich da gemacht habe, ein einzelner, transparenter Pixel. Aber ich dachte, okay, was ist das Kunstwerk, das einfach das am allerwenigsten wert sein müsste, weil einfach so wenig wie möglich drinsteckt, was so wenig wie möglich überhaupt existiert. Und das ist ein Bild von Einmal-Ein-Pixel-Abmessung und ohne irgendeine Farbe. Und das habe ich so als Statement dann auch irgendwo bei OpenSea, auf so einer Plattform gemintet, einfach um diese Absurdität, diesen Unterschied zwischen Wert und Preis darzustellen. Habe dabei erschreckenderweise festgestellt oder nachher ausgerechnet, dass dieses Ding dann theoretisch, also diese einzelne Aktion, über 100 Kilogramm CO2 verursacht haben soll, rein rechnerisch. Wenn man den Berechnungen glauben kann, was natürlich auch einfach katastrophal ist. Man muss natürlich da auch immer fairerweise unterscheiden zwischen dem CO2-Ausstoß von Blockchain, Krypto, NFT und dem Energieverbrauch. Weil das Energieverbrauch mit einem CO2-Ausstoß korreliert, ist zum Teil auch einfach immer noch ein Versagen der Politik, die den Wandel zu erneuerbaren Energien nicht geschafft hat, wenn wir alle unsere Energie aus Ökostrom kriegen würden.
Das ginge aber schneller, wenn wir nicht Energie für Blockchain ausgeben würden. Das ist ja auch ein Zeltbeschluss.
Wie meinst du das?
Naja, pass auf. Das Umstellen auf erneuerbare Energien fordert ja, dass wir Quellen für erneuerbare Energien schaffen, dass wir Solarzellen aufstellen, Windkrafträder aufstellen usw. In dem Moment, wo du mehr Energie verbrauchst, als du eigentlich benötigen würdest ohne Blockchain, machst es halt schwerer, auf erneuerbare Energien umzustellen. Du kannst nicht auf der einen Seite den Energieverbrauch mit der Schaufel zum Fenster rauswerfen. Auf der anderen Seite sagen, die Politik hat es nicht geschafft, erneuerbare Energien einzuführen. Das ist schon so.
Das erfordert auch Energiesparen. Nein, nein, stopp. Aber das dann zu sagen, wir haben zu wenig erneuerbare Energie, weil Blockchain, das ist schon auch kurz gegriffen. Da kannst du auch sagen, wir müssen nicht alle Auto fahren, wir müssen nicht alle fliegen und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist richtig, aber zu sagen, na ja, gut, auf Blockchain verzichten wir jetzt nicht, aber wofür dann? Also dann kommt der nächste und sagt, auf Auto fahren verzichten wir nicht. Der nächste kommt und sagt, auf Fliegen verzichten wir nicht. Also eine Umstellung auf eine CO2-freie Wirtschaft erfordert auch Energiesparen. Und an der Stelle muss man einfach den Sinn und den Unsinn von Energieverbrauch hinterfragen. Und das betrifft ein Auto genauso wie eine Blockchain.
Da hast du absolut recht. Ich meine nur, wenn wir von Anfang an immer schon nur erneuerbare Energien benutzt hätten, dann gäbe es keine Diskussion über einen CO2-Ausstoß von NFT. Das wollte ich nur sagen.
Nee, weißt du, worüber wir dann diskutieren würden? Über Blackouts wegen mangelnder Energieversorgung. Also ich denke, diesen Punkt werden wir auch noch erreichen.
Dann sprechen wir aber nicht unbedingt über den Energieverbrauch von NFT, sondern eher um den Anstieg, der da durch die vermehrte Nutzung oder durch die brunghaft vermehrte Nutzung jetzt gerade, also dass jetzt die Infrastrukturen da nicht entsprechend hinterherziehen. Das kann man jetzt nur bedingt den Kryptowährungen oder den NFTs jetzt selber vorwerfen.
Ich würde aber nochmal bei den NFTs landen wollen, weil mir scheint, das ist ein Thema, ein Metathema, das sich bei Blockchain wiederholt ist. Es wird auf gesellschaftliche Probleme draufgeworfen, klärt diese nicht, führt aber dazu, dass Leute, die eh gut im Spekulieren sind, spekulieren, also der Teufelscheiß auf den größten Haufen, konkret. Vor allen Dingen profitieren von NFTs Spekulateure. Es hilft den Künstlerinnen nichts und es maskiert damit ein Problem auf eine liberale, libertäre Art und Weise, eine neoliberale Art und Weise. Im Prinzip sind wir als Gesellschaft daran interessiert, Künstlerinnen zu haben. Diese Künstlerinnen sollen auch leben können und das möglichst auch gut. Weil es eben kein System gibt, was das gewährleistet, führt das jetzt dazu, dass es NFTs gibt, die aber dann nicht das Problem klären, nämlich dass Künstlerinnen gut davon leben können. Also ein paar ja, aber viele eben auch nicht, wie du gesagt hast. Dafür ist der Spekulationsmarkt wieder um ein weiteres Spekulationsobjekt gestiegen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich sag mal so, auch mit NFT ist da immer noch eine Monopolisierung gegeben. Das heißt, die Leute, die vorher mit digitaler Kunst oder anderer Kunst gut verdient haben, die verdienen auch mit NFT mehr. Aber grundsätzlich ist die Schere zwischen den Gutverdienenden und den Nichtsverdienenden kleiner geworden oder ist aktuell kleiner gewesen. Also da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Leute, die vorher auch noch nie irgendetwas mit Kunst verdient hatten und plötzlich am NFT-Markt etwas verkaufen konnten, selbst wenn es nur daran lag, dass überreiche Spekulanten plötzlich sinnlos deren Kunst gekauft haben.
Also das Problem, das ich so ein bisschen damit habe, zum einen mit Zehntum gab es schon immer. Also Leute mit zu viel Geld haben schon immer die Kunst gefördert. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch gut und richtig. Aber das ist so ein bisschen das The Winner Takes It All Prinzip. Oder wie die FDP sagen würde, Chancengleichheit. Es kann halt jeder mit der gleichen Chance im Lotto gewinnen. In der Praxis trifft das aber nicht alle, sondern es trifft ein paar. Die schwimmen dann im Geld und der Rest hat auch wieder keine Kohle. Vom Ansatz her gefällt mir einfach so etwas wie Patreon zum Supporten von Künstlern besser. Jeder tut seine zwei Euro im Topf im Monat. Wenn sich genügend Leute finden, die Kunst gut finden, kann man davon auch leben. Bei einem NFT musst du halt den einen finden, der dir das dann komplett auszahlt für dieses eine Kunstwerk anstatt dass tausend Leute sagen, das finde ich geil, da schmeiße ich was in den Hut für. Mich stört dieses überspitzte, mit Zehntum, Milliardäre, leisten es sich bestimmte Künstler und alles, was damit einhergeht, irgendwie hip zu sein, sich zu zeigen und so weiter und so fort. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz enorm. Meiner Meinung nach nicht der beste Ansatz, um Kunst zu fördern, Künstler zu fördern.
Also ich komme nicht auf einen grünen Zweig, kann man das, glaube ich, zusammenfassen, weil alles, was mit Blockchain zu tun hat und NFTs auch, ist immer sozusagen sehr hart hinterfragbar. Und ja, das hat vielleicht eine Berechtigung. Aber bei allen Beispielen, die wir heute verhandelt haben, frage ich mich immer, würde das auch so existieren ohne die Spekulation dahinter? Also ohne eben dieses Scam-System, kann man fast schon sagen, wo es halt dann nur darum geht, eine künstliche Knappheit eigentlich zu erzeugen und Ressourcen zu verschwenden. Also im Prinzip bezahlen wir, wir jetzt als Welt, in Energie und Chip-Knappheit, dass Leute spekulieren können. Und das, also mich spricht das persönlich nicht an. Falls ihr das anders seht, könnt ihr es gerne, oder auch genauso, könnt ihr es gerne in die Kommentare schreiben. Ich würde jetzt noch eine Abschlussrunde machen wollen und jedem von euch eine Frage in zwei Teilen stellen. Nämlich, sollte Blockchain weggehen und wird Blockchain weggehen? Peter?
Ja und ja.
Aber warum?
Ich bin jetzt berühmt dafür, mich hier kurz zu fassen. Ja, also sollte, sollte Blockchain weggehen. Also vielleicht gibt es irgendwo einen Endwendungsfall, der tatsächlich Sinn ergibt, den ich dann auch unterschreiben würde und um das auch nochmal klar zu sagen, ich finde die Technologie als solche durchaus spannend. Also da haben sich schlaue Leute schlaue Gedanken gemacht, das ist interessant, allerdings eher von einem akademischen Standpunkt heraus. Also ich finde, wie gesagt, in der freien Welt da draußen habe ich immer noch nichts gesehen, was mich irgendwie überzeugt und so die ganz rapiden Nachteile, die hatten wir jetzt alle schon durchdekliniert, insbesondere was die Energieverschwendung angeht. Und ich bin auch bei Andreas, dass mir so ein Patreon-System vom Grundsatz her besser gefällt als wieder eine Blockchain. Und ich habe halt immer den Eindruck, dass Dinge mit Zwang auf Blockchain gehievt werden, weil es halt gerade geht und Leute verzweifelt irgendeine Anwendungsweise suchen, mit dem man dann wiederum Venture Capital einsammeln kann. Und das führt irgendwie zunächst eigentlich nur zu Ressourcenverschwendung. Das ist eben nicht der Meinung, dass sie gehen sollte. Und ich glaube, dass sie geht, weil sich dieses Memen, dass Blockchain total sicher ist und alles besser macht, bemerkenswert penetrant hält bis jetzt. Aber jedes Memen hat seine Zeit und das wird dafür auch gelten. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass ich da die, also ich merke das auch schon so ein bisschen im politischen und Industriebereich, dann lichtet sich ein wenig so der Himmel. Also ich denke, das Memen ist gerade wieder am Absterben und ich glaube, das wird deswegen auch gehen.
Aber das ist zu sagen, das gilt für die Verbreitung der Idee, Blockchain, Bitcoin wird wahrscheinlich bleiben und ist ja real, oder?
Ja, ich denke schon. Also Bitcoin wird uns auf jeden Fall noch ein Weilchen begleiten. Ich würde mir nicht zutrauen zu mutmaßen, wie das denn mit dem Kurs aussehen wird. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass sich das wieder ein bisschen normalisiert und zurückgeht. Und ich denke, es wird ein permanenter Randeffekt werden. Mal gucken.
Andreas?
Ich finde, also tatsächlich ist Blockchain auch eine faszinierende Technologie, aber auch Atombomben sind eine faszinierende Technologie. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es sie geben sollte auf unserem Planeten. Also insbesondere Proof of Work muss verschwinden. Das ist ein Riesenproblem, ist eine Riesenumweltsäure. Es wird nicht besser werden. Das wird uns das Klimakosten, es wird uns im Kopf einen Kragen bringen. Das muss verschwinden. Ich mag nicht vorherzusagen, ob eine der alternativen Technologien die Möglichkeit hat, da ersatz zu sein. Also Festplattenplatz ist keine Alternative, weil auch der kostet Ressourcen. Also alles, was sozusagen mit dem Horden physischer Ressourcen zu tun hat, ist meines Erachtens ungeeignet. Vielleicht hat Proof of Stake eine Chance. Ich habe einen Algorithmus gesehen, der relativ interessant probabilistisch arbeitet. Wenn man eine Münze der Währung in der Tasche hat, ist es sozusagen ein Ticket für die Lotterie, mitten in der Blockchain teilnehmen zu dürfen. Und wenn man halt gerade online ist, dann darf man auch mitmachen und kriegt ausgezahlt. Das kann funktionieren. Mit Sicherheit gibt es Anwendungen, die im internationalen Warenverkehr über reine Spekulationen hinausgehen. Die habe ich, glaube ich, erwähnt. Das wird auch nicht weggehen. Auch ein Fass, das wir heute nicht aufmachen wollen mit der Drogenlegalisierung, aber wird zu viel mit der Kopf behalten. Was ich hoffe, ist, dass der Hype weggeht. Und was ich hoffe, dass, ich denke, das wird es auch, dieses irgendwie, naja, ich habe Blockchain als Hammer, also sieht jedes Problem bei einem Nagel aus, weggeht. Es gibt bessere verteilte Datenbanken, es gibt bessere Mechanismen, um Hashes über Daten zu bilden. Und für die allermeisten Fälle gibt es auch bessere Konsensalgorithmen.
Also ich glaube, dass Blockchain in unserer technologisierten und kapitalistischen Welt so die zweitbeste Lösung ist, die wir haben. Und mich fasziniert vor allem diese Idee des Dezertalisierten. Und ich glaube, da wird noch viel kommen in Richtung, also das Potenzial von Smart Contracting wird noch viel stärker mal ausgenutzt werden. Vor allem, wenn es auch weggeht von diesen ganzen Spekulativen, wenn der ganze Energieverbrauch mal reduziert wird, wenn man sich dann mal damit befasst, wie man eben auch politische Entscheidungsprozesse damit unterstützen kann. Und sei es jetzt nicht nur darum, dass, also ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass die Technologie Blockchain bestehen bleibt, aber ich glaube, dass sie wertvolle Impulse für neue Gedanken liefern wird in Richtung Dezentralisierung. Und dass es dann zu so einem Umdecken kommt, zu dem, was eben angesprochen wurde, Patreon, sowas in die Richtung. Das ist ja auch nur ein Schritt in die Richtung, dass alle Leute einfach cool miteinander sind, keiner mehr spekulieren muss, weil jeder dem anderen das Essen gibt, was er braucht. Darüber reden wir, da wollen wir eigentlich hin. Und ich glaube, in die Richtung kann uns Blockchain gedanklich ein bisschen bringen, deswegen glaube ich, im Moment Strom für die Blockchain ist power to the people.
Okay, ich glaube, viel weiter auseinander sind wir selten mal im Chaosradio geendet. Und ich würde das gerne an dieser Stelle einfach so stehen lassen. Mich bei euch bedanken, Max, Peter und Andreas, dass ihr heute da wart. Vielen Dank, Dankeschön. Und bei euch, liebe Hörerinnen, dass ihr so geduldig zugehört habt und lasst uns wie gesagt gerne wissen, was ihr von dem Thema habt. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Oft ist das ja so in der Chaosradio-Bubble, dass das Themen, sagen wir mal, aus einer eindeutigen Perspektive besetzt sind, wie es hier ist, würde mich sehr interessieren. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, mir bleibt nur noch, mich zu verabschieden, ganz ohne Blockchain und zu sagen, lasst sie nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.